dans les tranchées l'odeur de la mort
règne les rats nous envahissent les
parasites nous ronge la peau nous vivons
dans la boue une lettre rédigée à verdun
lors de la première guerre mondiale
c'est avec ce support que travaille huit
adolescents des clayes-sous-bois encadré
par un écrivain de la liberté et la
douce l'idée c'est de voir quelle quelle
lettre les générations d'aujourd'hui
pourrait écrire aux poilus qui était
dans les tranchées qui faisait la guerre
de 14 18
donc ce qu'on a fait aujourd'hui dans
une première étape de travail c'est
faire un brainstorming pour dégager des
mots clés des grandes idées miroir
d'histoire un projet mené dans le cadre
du centenaire de la première guerre
mondiale pour sensibiliser les
participants
en parallèle de cette lettre et avec
l'aide d'un photographe le luan et
margot réalise un diaporama
on a posé sur une feuille des idées des
mots en rapport avec ben haddou thèmes
et ja photo on va essayer de transmettre
avec des images j'ai très envie de
pleurer parce que c'est quand même une
aide très très très très belle après ça
tombe dans l'oubli et c'est dommage que
de telles choses tombent dans l'oubli
après tout ce que les soldats
ont pu faire pour nous les adolescents
ont jusqu'à la fin des vacances pour
terminer leurs travaux ils doivent
encore enregistrer leurs lettres sur un
fond musical
en novembre la ville organise une série
d'événements autour du centenaire
le public pourra découvrir leurs
réalisations lors de la soirée de
lancement à l'espace philippe noiret